This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Lisa, tell them about our new show. We have a new podcast. It's called Don't Lie to Me. I'm Lexi Youanu. We're two best friends, 22 years apart, but so close at heart.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。丽莎，告诉他们关于我们新节目的事。我们有一个新播客。它叫《别对我撒谎》。我是莱克西·尤阿努。我们是两个最好的朋友，相差22岁，但心却贴得很近。
And I'm Lisa Di Giulio, the old one, which means we have wildly different references, occasionally different opinions, and at this point in my 50s, I've lived it all. Now in my 30s, being the founder of new shoes, good taste is my business. Listen on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Lacey Mosley, author, actor, stand-up comedian, creator, and host of Scam Goddess Podcasts.
我是丽莎·迪·朱利奥，年纪大的那个，这意味着我们有截然不同的参考系，偶尔有不同的观点，而且在我50多岁的现在，我已经经历了一切。现在我30多岁，作为新鞋的创始人，好品味是我的事业。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。我是莱西·莫斯利，作家、演员、单口喜剧演员、创作者，也是《骗局女神》播客的主持人。
The True Crime Comedy Podcasts all about robbery, fraud, and those who practice it. Each week I bring on an amazing guest. Ooh, I scammed them. What? I can talk to you for an hour. You're a generational yapper like me. That's why I had to make yapping a job. And now you can catch full episodes of my show on YouTube.
这是一档关于抢劫、欺诈以及那些行骗之人的真实犯罪喜剧播客。每周我都会请来一位了不起的嘉宾。噢，我骗了他们。什么？我可以和你聊一个小时。你和我一样是个爱唠叨的世代。这就是为什么我必须把唠叨变成一份工作。现在你可以在YouTube上观看我节目的完整剧集。
Start listening to Scam Goddess on the Icom. Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hi, this is Kylie Breakman. Angel Geratana. Jeremy Colhain. Patrick McDonald. And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists on Artists Podcast. The Improvised Character Comedy Podcast where each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft. Join us for a panel of Eurovision participants.
开始在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《骗局女神》。嗨，我是凯莉·布雷克曼。安吉尔·杰拉塔纳。杰里米·科尔汉。帕特里克·麦克唐纳。我们是《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》播客的主持人。这是一档即兴角色喜剧播客，每周都有一个新的艺术家小组讨论他们的技艺。加入我们，一起听听欧洲歌唱大赛参赛者的小组讨论。
And we do a little Halloween sometimes. Does the Pope dress up? He winks on Halloween. He gets right up next to the microphone. I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween. Listen to artists on artists on artists every Thursday on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们有时也会过万圣节。教皇会打扮吗？他在万圣节会眨眼。他直接凑到麦克风前。我听说你几乎能听到睫毛撞击的声音。你从未见过意大利像教皇在万圣节眨眼时那样安静。每周四在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》。
Welcome to Decoding Women's Health. I'm Dr. Elizabeth Pointer, chair of Women's Health and Gynecology at the Atria Health Institute in New York City. I'll be talking to top researchers and clinicians and bringing vital information about midlife women's health directly to you. A hundred percent of women go through menopause. Even if it's natural, why should we suffer through it? Listen to decoding women's health with Dr. Elizabeth Pointer on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You broke me. You do not deserve happiness. I'm Andrea Gunning. On this season of betrayal,
欢迎收听《解码女性健康》。我是伊丽莎白·波因特医生，纽约市阿特里亚健康研究所女性健康与妇科系主任。我将与顶尖的研究人员和临床医生交谈，并直接为您带来关于中年女性健康的重要信息。百分之百的女性都会经历更年期。即使它是自然的，我们为什么要忍受它呢？请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听伊丽莎白·波因特医生主持的《解码女性健康》。你毁了我。你不配拥有幸福。我是安德里亚·甘宁。在本季的《背叛》中，
Carl thought he was living a normal, drama-free life until the messages started. is not going to make it out of this alive. Every piece of evidence pointed to the wrong guy. He was not going to stop unless we stopped him. Listen to Betrayal Season 6 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our
卡尔以为他过着正常、没有戏剧性的生活，直到那些信息开始出现。他活不成了。每一条证据都指向了错误的人。除非我们阻止他，否则他不会停手。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《背叛》第六季。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，这是一个我们讨论20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们意味着什么的播客。
psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so lovely to have you here back around these parts today as we discussed the psychology of our 20s, specifically the five reasons you are not as behind as you think. This has to be one of the most prominent, I would say the most widely felt experiences of our 20s and probably our 30s as well. This sense that life is this race, there is a big checklist of things that we need to do and we need to accomplish, and we are all simultaneously failing. There is somebody ahead of us who is doing more, who is accomplished more, and if we don't catch up to them and we don't catch up to them soon, well, some big bad thing is going to transpire, and we're never going to be happy,
心理学。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。今天能在这里见到大家真是太好了，正如我们讨论的《20多岁的心理学》，特别是你并没有你想象中那么落后的五个原因。这一定是20多岁，可能还有30多岁时最突出、我可以说最广泛感受到的体验之一。这种感觉就是生活是一场竞赛，有一张巨大的待办事项清单，我们需要做，需要完成，而我们所有人都在同时失败。总有人走在我们前面，做得更多，成就更高，如果我们不赶上他们，而且不尽快赶上他们，好吧，一些糟糕的大事就会发生，我们将永远不会快乐，
we're never going to be successful, we're going to be miserable for the rest of our lives. I have felt this countless times in my 20s so far. I genuinely feel like it's my little emotional shadow at this stage. And I'm fairly certain a lot of you have felt it as well, which is kind of funny. And it's ironic because if we are all feeling behind, who exactly is ahead? Like, it's a tricky feeling. What we have to realize is that this feeling is actually one of our brain's favorite ways to catastrophize. And yet a lot of what it tells us is highly, highly inaccurate.
我们将永远不会成功，我们将余生都在痛苦中度过。到目前为止，我在20多岁时已经无数次感受到这一点。我真诚地觉得它在这个阶段就像我的小情绪阴影。而且我相当肯定你们很多人也感受到了，这有点好笑。这很讽刺，因为如果我们都觉得落后，那到底谁在前面呢？这是一种棘手的感觉。我们必须意识到，这种感觉实际上是我们大脑最喜欢的灾难化方式之一。然而，它告诉我们的很多事情都是高度、高度不准确的。
it. And it's based on a series of cognitive fallacies that we can actually counteract and really dig into and disprove. So today I actually want to break down these fallacies. I want to break them down one by one so that you can kind of view your situation and the sensation of feeling behind a bit more realistically and hopefully realize like how far ahead you are, how much progress you've made, why you are exactly where you need to be, and how to release this anxiety before it causes you to make irrational decisions or to not like yourself because that's one of the worst things you can do when you are up against this feeling. So without further ado, let's get into the five reasons you are not as behind as you think based on the psychology. So the first reason
它基于一系列认知谬误，我们实际上可以抵消并深入研究并反驳它们。所以今天我实际上想拆解这些谬误。我想一个一个地拆解它们，这样你就可以更现实地看待你的处境和那种落后的感觉，并希望意识到你领先了多少，你取得了多少进步，为什么你正处于你需要处于的位置，以及如何在它导致你做出非理性决定或不喜欢自己之前释放这种焦虑，因为当你面对这种感觉时，这是你能做的最糟糕的事情之一。所以事不宜迟，让我们进入基于心理学的你并没有你想象中那么落后的五个原因。所以第一个原因
you're not as behind as you imagine yourself to be actually has, I think, very little to do with what you have or haven't accomplished or what you have or haven't done. And it has everything to do with who and how you compare yourself to others. One of the main reasons I think you may feel behind is that when you compare yourself to other people of, let's say, around the same age, who are pursuing the same goals that you want to pursue, oftentimes you are comparing yourself to the very best or the most visible version of this. And that is what's making you miserable. This is a cognitive bias. It actually has a name. It's called the survivorship bias. And it occurs when we mistake the subgroup of the most successful as the entire group. And because we aren't what we would deem one of the most
你并没有你想象中那么落后，实际上我认为这与你已经完成或未完成的事情，或者你已经做或未做的事情关系不大。它完全与你比较的对象以及你如何比较自己有关。我认为你可能感到落后的主要原因之一是，当你把自己与大约相同年龄、正在追求你想要追求的目标的其他人进行比较时，通常你是在与这个群体中最优秀或最显眼的版本进行比较。而这正是让你痛苦的原因。这是一种认知偏差。它实际上有一个名字。它被称为幸存者偏差。当我们把最成功的小群体误认为是整个群体时，就会发生这种情况。而且因为我们不是我们所认为的
successful, we therefore, you know, we're not part of the majority. We are not part of this group of everybody else who's doing great. We are in this small special group of failures. These kind of groups don't exist. Social media especially is one of the main corporate here and making us feel this way, when that's not how life works. You know, it's, it's normal to experience comparison. It's normal to really pay attention to success stories. But I think nowadays, because people, you know, choose to share so much more, social media gives the impression of visibility over others' lives that gives the impression of a full story when actually, even that full story is still curated. Like, even when we are seeing other people,
最成功的人之一，所以，你知道，我们不是多数派的一部分。我们不是这个做得很好的大家庭的一部分。我们处于这个失败者的小特殊群体中。这种群体并不存在。社交媒体尤其是一个主要的罪魁祸首，让我们有这种感觉，而生活并不是那样运作的。你知道，经历比较是正常的。真正关注成功故事是正常的。但我认为现在，因为人们，你知道，选择分享得更多，社交媒体给人一种对他人生活可见性的印象，给人一种完整故事的印象，而实际上，即使是那个完整的故事也是经过精心策划的。就像，即使当我们看到其他人
people's failures, they are still the failures that they have chosen to show us. There is still some kind of facade that makes things always look polished. I'm somebody with a social media presence. I would say it's a modest one, but still. And I've even found that like if I share vulnerable stuff and if I share my failures, I kind of only shared like sexy failures. Like I'm not sharing the full extent of things. And I'm definitely not sharing the regularity at which they're happening. Like, I'm not going to talk about business failures or financial failures or tax failures or family failures, mainly for privacy, if I'm, if I'm being honest. But I do still think, like, I know I'm doing it. I know everybody else is doing it. And I know that it's contributing
的失败时，它们仍然是他们选择展示给我们的失败。仍然存在某种让事情看起来总是光鲜亮丽的假象。我是一个在社交媒体上有存在感的人。我会说这是一个适度的存在感，但仍然如此。我甚至发现，如果我分享脆弱的东西，如果我分享我的失败，我有点只分享了那种“性感的失败”。就像我没有分享事情的全部程度。而且我绝对没有分享它们发生的频率。就像，我不会谈论商业失败、财务失败、税务失败或家庭失败，如果我诚实的话，主要是为了隐私。但我确实仍然认为，就像，我知道我在这样做。我知道其他人也在这样做。而且我知道它正在促成
to this collective image that we know our own pain and we know our own failures very well. We think we know others because we think we have this visibility over their lives. We really don't. We really don't. And I think we We all know, like, yeah, social media is fake. But even the stuff that doesn't look fake is still sometimes fake. That's what I'm trying to say, you know. And then on top of that, like, the content that doesn't talk about that stuff still continues to rise to the surface.
这种集体形象，我们非常了解自己的痛苦和失败。我们认为我们了解别人，因为我们认为我们对他们的生活有这种可见性。我们真的没有。我们真的没有。而且我认为我们都知道，就像，是的，社交媒体是假的。但即使是看起来不假的东西有时也是假的。这就是我想说的，你知道。然后除此之外，就像，不谈论那些事情的内容仍然继续浮出水面。
Content that is lavish, successful, that shows a very particular kind of lifestyle is compelling and is something that we are going to pay more attention to, especially since we don't see it very often in the real world. Science backs this up. It backs up the fact that social media is literally optimized to show us aspirational content. I would really recommend this book. It's called The Chaos Machine by Mark Fisher. And he dives into this more. And what he basically says is how Instagram and TikTok is a machine that was programmed by people who really understood the brain. and it works because it selects the most provocative and emotional content and feeds that to us. That means the bad stuff, obviously, but it also just means a selection of outliers.
奢华、成功、展示某种特定生活方式的内容是引人注目的，是我们会更加关注的东西，特别是因为我们在现实世界中并不经常看到它。科学支持这一点。它支持社交媒体实际上被优化以向我们展示令人向往的内容这一事实。我真的会推荐这本书。它叫《混沌机器》，作者是马克·费舍尔。他更深入地研究了这一点。他基本上说的是Instagram和TikTok是如何成为一台由真正了解大脑的人编程的机器。它之所以有效，是因为它选择了最具挑衅性和情感性的内容并将其喂给我们。这意味着坏事，显然，但也只是意味着对异常值的选择。
It shows us outliers, which is why we only ever see the most lavish, perfect version of life or the most awful tragedies or the most shocking stuff. And we would, if we're, you know, it's natural, we're seeing that all the time, begin to think that that's all the world is. And the reason that we're getting shown this stuff is because it triggers an emotional reaction. It triggers envy. It triggers comparison. It triggers confusion, jealousy, all of which are complex emotions that keep us going back to the source.
它向我们展示异常值，这就是为什么我们总是只看到生活最奢华、最完美的一面，或者最可怕的悲剧，或者最令人震惊的事情。如果我们，你知道，这是自然的，我们一直看到这些，就会开始认为世界就是这样。我们被展示这些东西的原因是因为它触发了情绪反应。它触发了嫉妒。它触发了比较。它触发了困惑、嫉妒，所有这些都是复杂的，让我们不断回到源头的情绪。
Keep us going back to social media. A study from 2022 actually had, I think it was like 300 people in the US look at 20 social media influencer posts. And afterwards, they measured their, effective well-being, effective well-being basically means like the intensity of your positive and negative emotions. And they also measured their level of envy and their level of inspiration towards the influencer. What the study revealed was a negative correlation between looking at social media posts and well-being. They also noticed a positive correlation, I will say, between this same feeling and occasionally feelings of inspiration, but only when the content or the
让我们不断回到社交媒体。2022年的一项研究实际上让，我想大约有300名美国人看了20个社交媒体网红的帖子。之后，他们测量了他们的情感幸福感，情感幸福感基本上意味着你积极和消极情绪的强度。他们还测量了他们的嫉妒水平和他们对网红的灵感水平。研究揭示的是看社交媒体帖子与幸福感之间的负相关。我还要说，他们还注意到这种相同的感觉与偶尔的灵感感觉之间存在正相关，但只有当内容或
lifestyle felt reachable. And most of it doesn't. And most of us just gives us the impression that we are absolutely failing at life. We are existing in these online environments, sometimes for six plus hours a day. And these are environments that are designed to intentionally make you feel bad about yourself. I don't think it's the content creator's fault. I think it's what gets pushed and what becomes popular. And so the reason you feel so behind is because you are sitting in this artificial space that's just meant to make you feel really bad about yourself. And I think you would notice that if you got off your phone, even for a couple of days, got off social media even for a couple of days, if you stepped out of this atmosphere environment, like this space, you would feel so much
生活方式感觉触手可及的时候。而大部分内容并非如此。我们大多数人只是给我们一种我们绝对在生活中失败的印象。我们有时每天在这些在线环境中存在超过六个小时。而这些环境旨在故意让你对自己感觉不好。我不认为这是内容创作者的错。我认为这是被推动和变得流行的东西。所以你感到如此落后的原因是因为你坐在这种旨在让你对自己感觉非常糟糕的人造空间里。而且我认为如果你放下手机，哪怕几天，离开社交媒体哪怕几天，如果你走出这种氛围环境，就像这个空间，你会感觉好得多
better. And you would actually just realize and have this deep epiphany of how normal most people's lives are and how well you really are doing. You know, even if you're not where you want to be yet, I truly do believe, like maybe you're just exactly where you need to be. Not everyone can be the most successful version of themselves in their 20s. In fact, I actually, I don't think it's that healthy to be that. I don't think it's healthy to be the best at something and to be everything you've ever wanted to be at 25. So don't discount your progress and your achievements just because somebody is doing more or because you think that you could be doing more. Sometimes it's all, it happens according to plan.
而且你实际上会意识到并有这种深刻的顿悟，即大多数人的生活是多么正常，以及你实际上做得有多好。你知道，即使你还没有达到你想要的位置，我真的相信，也许你正处于你需要处于的位置。并不是每个人都能在20多岁时成为他们自己最成功的版本。事实上，我实际上，我不认为成为那样是健康的。我不认为在25岁时成为某件事的最强者并成为你一直想成为的一切是健康的。所以不要仅仅因为别人做得更多，或者因为你认为你可以做得更多，就否定你的进步和成就。有时这一切，它按计划发生。
It all is going to be okay. I also believe that we get into this trap of like feeling like we're behind because And this is the second reason we feel behind. We treat envy like it is something to be avoided rather than something that can actually be useful or manageable. Now, that might sound like it contradicts what I just said. You know, I just said like social media makes us feel bad because it elicits feelings of jealousy. And jealousy in itself must be negative and hurtful and wrong. Therefore, we must avoid social media, get away from it so that the jealous feelings go away. I want to explain this a little bit further, though, because that's actually not what I mean. We cannot separate the feeling of envy and the feeling of being behind. That also means that if we treat envy differently and we change our relationship to it, our sense of being behind will also perhaps lessen and also improve. Typically, when we, I would say, I would say this is for the majority of people when we experience an emotion like envy or jealousy or anything like that. Our greatest reaction is just to like get a
一切都会好起来的。我还相信我们陷入了这种陷阱，就像觉得我们落后了，因为这是我们感到落后的第二个原因。我们对待嫉妒就像它是需要避免的东西，而不是可以实际利用或管理的东西。现在，这听起来可能与我刚才说的相矛盾。你知道，我刚才说社交媒体让我们感觉不好，因为它引起了嫉妒的感觉。而嫉妒本身一定是消极、伤人和错误的。因此，我们必须避免社交媒体，远离它，这样嫉妒的感觉就会消失。不过，我想进一步解释这一点，因为那实际上不是我的意思。我们不能把嫉妒的感觉和落后的感觉分开。这也意味着如果我们以不同的方式对待嫉妒，并改变我们与它的关系，我们的落后感也可能会减轻并得到改善。通常，当我们，我会说，我会说这是大多数人，当我们经历像嫉妒或羡慕或任何类似的情绪时。我们最大的反应只是像得到一个
far away from it as possible, like really psychologically put as much distance between us and that feeling as we can. We've definitely been socialized that jealousy is bad, it's unpleasant, it's uncomfortable, it's selfish. So when it naturally comes up because it's a human emotion and it will, all that is met with is guilt and shame and self-judgment, and that just makes us feel really crap. Envy has levels and envy has layers to it that is not spoken about enough. There is benign envy and there is malicious envy.
尽可能远离它，就像在心理上尽可能在我们和那种感觉之间拉开距离。我们绝对被社会化了，认为嫉妒是不好的，是不愉快的，是不舒服的，是自私的。所以当它自然出现时，因为它是一种人类情感，它会，所有这些都伴随着内疚、羞耻和自我评判，这只会让我们感觉真的很糟糕。嫉妒有层次，嫉妒有层面，没有被谈论得足够多。有良性嫉妒，也有恶意嫉妒。
malicious envy creates inferiority means that we may try and tear somebody down, disregard them, undermine them. Malicious envy is not helpful and it's the kind of envy that ruins our self-esteem and it doesn't make us feel good. It doesn't make us a good person either. The nine envy or emulative envy on the other hand is actually motivational and it's aspirational. And so what that means is that it encourages us to actually do more. And I think this is for two reasons. The first reason why benign or emulative envy helps us be better is that if we are jealous of a situation, that provides some of the clearest evidence that that is actually what you want in life.
恶意嫉妒产生自卑感，意味着我们可能会试图拆台某人，无视他们，破坏他们。恶意嫉妒没有帮助，它是那种破坏我们自尊的嫉妒，它不会让我们感觉良好。它也不会让我们成为一个好人。另一方面，良性嫉妒或模仿性嫉妒实际上是激励性的，是令人向往的。所以这意味着它鼓励我们实际上做得更多。而且我认为这是出于两个原因。良性或模仿性嫉妒帮助我们变得更好的第一个原因是，如果我们嫉妒某种情况，这提供了最清晰的证据，证明那实际上是你生活中想要的。
So the reason that envy, benign envy is helpful, it is like one of the clearest big red flags, big shining lights pointing to something that you secretly want and that you secretly desire. It is a mirror. like envy is a mirror because if you didn't secretly want that, why would you be having such an intense reaction about somebody who has it? Secondly, I think benign envy then shows us what is possible. We wouldn't feel jealous of something if it didn't exist. The proof that this person has it and exists is proof that we can also have it. Here's this person, I'm feeling this conflicting emotion. Perhaps the best direction for that emotion to take is towards curiosity and is about
所以嫉妒，良性嫉妒有帮助的原因是，它就像最清晰的巨大危险信号之一，巨大的闪亮灯光，指向你秘密想要和秘密渴望的东西。它是一面镜子。就像嫉妒是一面镜子，因为如果你不秘密想要那个，为什么你会对拥有它的人有如此强烈的反应？其次，我认为良性嫉妒然后向我们展示了什么是可能的。如果它不存在，我们就不会嫉妒某事。这个人拥有它并存在的事实证明我们也可以拥有它。这是这个人，我正在经历这种冲突的情绪。也许这种情绪最好的方向是走向好奇心，是关于
examining the steps that they took to obtain the thing that I really want for myself. Like, I want that life. I want that relationship. I want that feeling. So rethink envy, rethink the negative sensation that is attached to that feeling. And I think you, like, suddenly have access to such a powerful emotional force that you can harness. I read this. Actually, I don't think I read this. I think a friend told me about this interesting relationship that Michael Jackson and Prince had, and they had this, like, rivalry where they really drove each other to perform better. and Michael Jackson would be like, well, I have to do this because if I don't do it, like Prince is going to do it.
检查他们为了获得我真正想要的东西所采取的步骤。就像，我想要那种生活。我想要那种关系。我想要那种感觉。所以重新思考嫉妒，重新思考附着在这种感觉上的消极感觉。而且我认为你，就像，突然拥有了你可以利用的如此强大的情感力量。我读过这个。实际上，我不认为我读过这个。我想一个朋友告诉过我迈克尔·杰克逊和王子之间这种有趣的关系，他们有这种，就像，竞争，他们真的驱使对方表现得更好。迈克尔·杰克逊会说，好吧，我必须这样做，因为如果我不这样做，就像王子会做。
Like, Prince is going to steal my idea. And like it really pushed them both to like be the artist that they became and to have these like legendary legacies because they used envy as a compass and as a form of motivation. So I think that's another reason why you aren't as behind as you think. You're not treating envy in a way that it can help you. think if you were, you would realize that whilst you sit looking at somebody else's life feeling jealous of it, there is so much that maybe you could be doing to gain a life that's not the same, but might feel similar and might make you really happy. The other thing, and the third reason
就像，王子会偷走我的想法。而且它真的推动他们俩成为他们后来成为的艺术家，并拥有这些像传奇一样的遗产，因为他们把嫉妒当作指南针和一种动力。所以我认为这是你并没有你想象中那么落后的另一个原因。你没有以一种可以帮助你的方式对待嫉妒。我想如果你这样做了，你会意识到，当你坐着看着别人的生活并感到嫉妒时，也许你可以做很多事情来获得一种不完全相同，但可能感觉相似，并且可能让你真正快乐的生活。另一件事，以及第三个原因
why I think you feel behind, is because whilst you are comparing yourself to these phenomenal individuals, you might not realize how many people are comparing themselves to you. And you probably don't appreciate that you yourself are an outlier, especially in a global context. I don't, I think there is a lot that you are not giving yourself credit for that you should be. And I want to kind of shine a light on that after the short break. So stay with us. The music you love. Your favorite radio stations. Everywhere you go. The podcasts everyone's talking about. All in one place. And it's free.
为什么我认为你感到落后，是因为当你把自己与这些非凡的个人进行比较时，你可能没有意识到有多少人在把自己与你进行比较。而且你可能没有意识到你自己就是一个异常值，尤其是在全球背景下。我没有，我认为有很多你没有给予自己应得的认可。我想在短暂休息后阐明这一点。所以请和我们在一起。你喜爱的音乐。你最喜欢的广播电台。无论你走到哪里。每个人都在谈论的播客。都在同一个地方。而且它是免费的。
I heart radio Whatever you want to hear Listen anytime Anywhere Music, radio Podcasts Unlimited audio It's on the free
I heart radio 无论你想听什么 随时随地收听 音乐、广播 播客 无限音频 都在免费的
IHurt Radio app One app No subscription Always free Grab the free Every way you go Always free Download the free
IHurt Radio应用程序 一个应用程序 无需订阅 始终免费 获取免费的 无论你走到哪里 始终免费 下载免费的
IHard radio app today Lisa We should tell them about our new show Oh my God Lexi We have a new podcast It's called Don't Lie to Me I'm Lexi We're two best friends, 22 years apart, but so close at heart.
IHard radio应用程序今天 丽莎 我们应该告诉他们关于我们新节目的事 哦天哪 莱克西 我们有一个新播客 它叫《别对我撒谎》 我是莱克西 我们是两个最好的朋友，相差22岁，但心却贴得很近。
And I'm Lisa Di Giulio, the old one, which means we have wildly different references, occasionally different opinions, and at this point in my 50s, I've lived it all. I'm not going to get anyone fighting. That is wild. I learned that about you today. Now in my 30s, being the founder of new shoes, good taste is my business, and I've always got something to say. If men were just honest about this, there would be so much more peace in the world. We're going to talk about dating, relationships, beauty, getting older, and a little wiser. We're best friends, but we don't always agree.
我是丽莎·迪·朱利奥，年纪大的那个，这意味着我们有截然不同的参考系，偶尔有不同的观点，而且在我50多岁的现在，我已经经历了一切。我不会让任何人吵架。那太疯狂了。我今天了解到了关于你的这一点。现在我30多岁，作为新鞋的创始人，好品味是我的事业，我总是有话要说。如果男人对这一点诚实，世界上会有更多的和平。我们将谈论约会、关系、美容、变老，以及变得更聪明一点。我们是最好的朋友，但我们并不总是同意。
Because you told us how accommodating you are. Obviously, I would do what I think I could do to fight the fight, but there's only so much fight I can fight. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Liar. Listen on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast.
因为你告诉我们你有多么随和。显然，我会做我认为我能做的事去战斗，但战斗是有极限的。别对我撒谎。别对我撒谎。别对我撒谎。别对我撒谎。别对我撒谎。别对我撒谎。骗子。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast上收听。
or wherever you get your podcast. I don't really care. I'm Lacey Mosley, author, actor, stand-up comedian, creator, and host of Scam Goddess Podcasts, the True Crime Comedy Podcasts, all about robbery, fraud, and those who practice it. Each week I bring on incredible guests like Conan O'Brien, Iowa Debris, Lamorne Morris, and Nicole Byer.
或者任何你获取播客的地方。我真的不在乎。我是莱西·莫斯利，作家、演员、单口喜剧演员、创作者，也是《骗局女神》播客的主持人，这是一档关于抢劫、欺诈以及那些行骗之人的真实犯罪喜剧播客。每周我都会请来不可思议的嘉宾，比如柯南·奥布莱恩、阿约·埃德比里、拉莫恩·莫里斯和妮可·拜尔。
Ooh, I scammed them. What? I can talk to you for an hour. You're a generational yapper like me. That's why I had to make yapping a job. And the scams run the gamut. I'm talking about scams from the 1800s all the way up to today. I also warn you and keep you safe against scammers.
噢，我骗了他们。什么？我可以和你聊一个小时。你和我一样是个爱唠叨的世代。这就是为什么我必须把唠叨变成一份工作。而且骗局五花八门。我说的是从1800年代一直到今天的骗局。我还警告你并保护你免受骗子的伤害。
Call your grandparents. Tell your parents to stop clicking on links, please. And now you can catch full episodes of my show on YouTube. If there's a scam, I'm here to protect you. And I'm also here to laugh with you. So if you like fun, if you like comedy and you like learning and protecting yourself from criminals, start listening to scam goddess on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcast.
给你的祖父母打电话。请告诉你的父母停止点击链接。现在你可以在YouTube上观看我节目的完整剧集。如果有骗局，我在这里保护你。我也在这里和你一起笑。所以如果你喜欢乐趣，如果你喜欢喜剧，并且你喜欢学习和保护自己免受罪犯的伤害，开始在IHeart radio应用程序、Apple Podcast上收听《骗局女神》。或者任何你获取播客的地方。
Hi, this is Kylie Breakman, Angel Geratana, Jeremy Colhane, Patrick McDonald. And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists on Artists Podcast. The Improvised Character Comedy Podcasts where each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft. Join us for a panel of wellness influencers. What I try to do is faux journal. I don't know. Have you guys heard of faux journaling? Yeah, it's reading. It's called reading.
嗨，我是凯莉·布雷克曼、安吉尔·杰拉塔纳、杰里米·科尔汉、帕特里克·麦克唐纳。我们是《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》播客的主持人。这是一档即兴角色喜剧播客，每周都有一个新的艺术家小组讨论他们的技艺。加入我们，一起听听健康网红的小组讨论。我尝试做的是伪日记。我不知道。你们听说过伪日记吗？是的，那是阅读。它叫阅读。
So we don't like to use that word anymore. Okay. A panel of New York. Yorker cartoonists. Have you guys done Terry Gross's Peloton class? No! I've been dying too. I'm so sorry.
所以我们不喜欢再用那个词了。好的。一个《纽约客》漫画家小组。你们做过泰瑞·格罗斯的Peloton课程吗？没有！我一直想做。我很抱歉。
I'm seeing a reading of Sadako and the Thousand Paper Cranes by Audra McDonald's at the Wonderland Bookstore on 14th. That's crazy. I went to the Wonderland Bookstore yesterday and I heard Nora Jones do a reading of Zero Dark 30. No way. You have to come to the last bookstore, though. Kim Cottrell is reading the guitar tabs of yesterday. A panel of Eurovision participants. And we do a little Halloween sometimes.
我正在看奥德拉·麦克唐纳在第14街仙境书店朗读《佐佐子与一千只纸鹤》。那太疯狂了。我昨天去了仙境书店，我听到诺拉·琼斯朗读《猎杀本·拉登》。不可能。不过你必须来最后一家书店。金·卡特雷尔正在朗读《昨天》的吉他谱。一个欧洲歌唱大赛参赛者小组。我们有时也会过万圣节。
Does the Pope dress up? He winks on Halloween. It's right up next to the microphone. I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween. Listen to artists on artists on artists on artists on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. By age 11 or so, at least 70% have a phone. Middle school is a different world than the one we grew up in.
教皇会打扮吗？他在万圣节会眨眼。它直接凑到麦克风前。我听说你几乎能听到睫毛撞击的声音。你从未见过意大利像教皇在万圣节眨眼时那样安静。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》。到11岁左右，至少70%的人有手机。初中是一个与我们成长时不同的世界。
I'm Dr. Joy, and this is therapy for black girls. We spent real time on it in our surviving middle school run, bringing in a child psychologist and a psychiatrist who's raising two black girls of his own to talk about what's really going on with our kids right now. So it's literally physiological and neurological and psychological and psychological chaos happening all of the same job. We got into group chats and gaming,
我是乔伊医生，这是《黑人女孩治疗》。我们在“幸存初中”系列中投入了真正的时间，请来了一位儿童心理学家和一位正在抚养两个黑人女孩的精神科医生，谈谈我们的孩子现在到底在发生什么。所以这简直是生理、神经和心理上的混乱，同时发生。我们进入了群聊和游戏，
friendships and bullying, and how to tell the difference between healthy monitoring and the kind of surveillance that erodes trust. There's belonging. You could think of belonging as I can be myself and I can still be accepted. And then there's fitting in. Spitting in says I have to change who I am in order to avoid rejection. Then we turn the conversation toward the fathers,
友谊和欺凌，以及如何区分健康的监控和那种侵蚀信任的监视。有归属感。你可以把归属感看作是我可以做我自己，我仍然可以被接受。然后有融入感。融入感说我必须改变我是谁，以避免被拒绝。然后我们将谈话转向父亲们，
sitting down with therapist Keer Gaines on Black fatherhood and what it means to raise a daughter through this stage. You don't have on shorts so you can't do flips. You have on the dress. You have to cross your legs. That's the range of this run. From screen time to identity to the fathers doing the work at home. You have to get off her device.
与治疗师基尔·盖恩斯坐下来谈论黑人父亲身份，以及在这个阶段抚养女儿意味着什么。你没穿短裤，所以你不能做后空翻。你穿着裙子。你必须交叉双腿。这就是这个系列的范围。从屏幕时间到身份，再到在家工作的父亲们。你必须让她放下设备。
But the reality is there's a lot of life out there that we don't want you as your adults in their lives to miss out on. This has been our surviving middle school run. Brought to you by the people who spend their careers thinking about exactly this. I'm Dr. Joy. Listen to Therapy for Black Girls on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. I want to present some statistics for you here about what the average person is doing. and what the average person has achieved in their 20s, just so that we all, as a group, have a healthier perspective on like what is actually normal
但现实是，外面有很多生活，我们不希望你们作为他们生活中的成年人错过。这就是我们的“幸存初中”系列。由那些职业生涯中专门思考这个问题的人带给您。我是乔伊医生。在Iheart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《黑人女孩治疗》。我想在这里为你展示一些关于普通人正在做什么的统计数据，以及普通人在20多岁时取得了什么成就，只是为了让我们所有人，作为一个群体，对什么是真正正常的有一个更健康的视角
because I feel like we don't. So firstly, money. I'm just going to say, disclaimer, I'm going to base this on statistics from the UK because that's where I live now. But imagine, well, I don't think things would be that radically different to other countries that are perhaps similar. So do your own research on this, but I think that you would find it's probably quite similar. So, money. According to a 2026 finder survey, 18 to 24 year olds have an average of £3,000 in savings, whilst the average 25 to 34 year old has 11,000 pounds. You're probably thinking like, wait,
因为我觉得我们没有。所以首先，钱。我只是要说，免责声明，我将基于英国的统计数据，因为我现在住在那儿。但想象一下，嗯，我不认为事情会与可能相似的其他国家有那么大的不同。所以自己做这方面的研究，但我认为你会发现它可能非常相似。所以，钱。根据2026年Finder的一项调查，18至24岁的人平均有3000英镑的储蓄，而平均25至34岁的人有11000英镑。你可能在想，等等，
actually, that sounds like a lot. Remember the average is skewed. The average is skewed by people who have a lot of savings or people who have trust funds or who are high earners. In fact, that survey dug a little bit further, and it showed that two and five people of all ages have a thousand pounds or less in savings. A quarter, 25%, have 200 pounds less or less in savings, and 16% of people had no savings at all. That is a serious amount of people without much money. Forget being able to go on luxury holidays. Like, forget fancy clothes. The majority of people probably couldn't cover an emergency payment. And yet we are thinking that we are behind because we can't afford like the writs or a freaking designer handbag, thinking that
实际上，这听起来很多。记住平均值是倾斜的。平均值被那些有很多储蓄的人或那些有信托基金的人或高收入者所倾斜。事实上，那项调查进一步挖掘，显示每五个人中就有两个，无论年龄大小，储蓄都在一千英镑或以下。四分之一，25%，有200英镑或更少的储蓄，16%的人根本没有储蓄。那是一个没有多少钱的严重数量的人。别提能去豪华度假了。就像，别提昂贵的衣服。大多数人可能无法支付紧急付款。然而我们认为我们落后了，因为我们买不起像劳力士或该死的设计师手袋，认为
that is the norm. Now this isn't meant to be like making people feel bad and be like, look how awful everybody has it. Ha ha ha. Look how good. We have it. No. I just think it is so vital that you understand the norm and the global norm of what
那是常态。现在这并不是要让人们感觉不好，并说，看看每个人过得有多糟糕。哈哈哈哈。看看我们过得有多好。不。我只是认为理解常态和全球常态是非常重要的，
somebody your age is probably doing. Most people in their 20s cannot afford. all these fancy dinners at restaurants and trips and new clothes and just all the luxuries that we think that we need. What's more? Like maybe you can't afford that. It's probably wise not to choose those things as well. Like perhaps you are saving for a bigger purchase. You're trying to pay off debt. You're trying to help your family. Whatever it is, financial insecurity is actually more normal than not just financial security, but financial luxury. So put that in perspective. remember that next time you think, oh my God, I should be having, I should have more in my bank account.
你这个年纪的人可能在做什么。大多数20多岁的人负担不起所有这些在餐馆的昂贵晚餐、旅行、新衣服以及我们认为我们需要的所有奢侈品。更重要的是？就像也许你负担不起那个。选择那些东西可能也是不明智的。就像也许你正在为更大的购买存钱。你正在努力还清债务。你正在努力帮助你的家人。无论是什么，财务不安全实际上比财务安全，更不用说财务奢侈，更正常。所以把这一点放在视角中。记住这一点，下次你认为，哦天哪，我应该拥有，我应该在我的银行账户里有更多钱。
Another big one is, is home ownership. I feel like that is a very pressing thing in our 20s and 30s. The average age for home ownership is 34. Average, again, still skewed. And the number of people in that age is just getting higher and higher and higher because getting on the property ladder is is harder and harder and harder. Like, homeownership, money, the standard of we have in our mind, the standard that is our perception is highly different to the standard of this reality. Let's talk about some other non-material things. What about friends? How many friends do you think people have? You know, if you were basing this off of your own perception or what you see online, you would probably say the average person has 12 friends, 20 friends. The answer is the average person
另一个大问题是，是住房所有权。我觉得那是我们20多岁和30多岁时一个非常紧迫的事情。住房所有权的平均年龄是34岁。平均，再次，仍然是倾斜的。而且那个年龄段的人数只会越来越高，因为进入房地产市场越来越难。就像，住房所有权、金钱、我们脑海中的标准、作为我们感知的标准与这种现实的标准高度不同。让我们谈谈一些其他非物质的东西。朋友怎么样？你认为人们有多少朋友？你知道，如果你是基于你自己的感知或你在网上看到的东西，你可能会说普通人有12个朋友，20个朋友。答案是普通人
has one to four close friends. Additionally, actually the average person has like two friends. And we actually might only be able to psychologically manage having five close friends, according to what we know is Dunbar's number. Dunbar's number of theory of friendship was an idea put forward by this British psychologist. His name is Robin Dunbar in the 90s. He is my dream guest on the podcast. So if anybody, I've emailed him so many times. So I was going to say, if anybody has his number, he knows I'm trying to get a hold of him.
有一到四个亲密朋友。此外，实际上普通人大约有两个朋友。而且根据我们所知的邓巴数，我们实际上可能只能在心理上管理拥有五个亲密朋友。邓巴数的友谊理论是这位英国心理学家提出的一个想法。他的名字是罗宾·邓巴，在90年代。他是我的播客梦想嘉宾。所以如果任何人，我已经给他发过很多次邮件了。所以我本来想说，如果任何人有他的号码，他知道我正在试图联系他。
He doesn't want to come on the podcast. But what he basically said was that Alburn. and our capacity as social creatures is limited. And we really only have so many relationships that we can juggle. When we see somebody who has 30 close friends, 20 close friends, a group of friends, it's like 10 people and they all seem to get along, I really do think that there is stuff behind the scenes that like you probably don't know about. It's very easy to look at that and think, God, they must be so happy.
他不想来参加播客。但他基本上说的是，奥本。以及我们作为社会生物的能力是有限的。我们真的只有这么多我们可以应付的关系。当我们看到某人有30个亲密朋友、20个亲密朋友、一群朋友，大约有10个人，而且他们似乎都相处得很好，我真的认为幕后有一些你可能不知道的事情。看着那个并认为，天哪，他们一定很幸福，这非常容易，
God, what a luxury, and not realize how many internal disputes there are, how many people feel excluded at times, how many times those same people still feel very, very lonely. So that's another thing you have to be aware of when you're comparing. What about marriage? So about marriage and relationships and our relative norm versus the, like our perception versus the reality. Again, using the UK data, the average age, a person first marries is 31. In the 90s, oh, sorry, in the 70s it was 23. That is just the start. For every person getting married at 25, there's another person getting married at 35 or 40 or in their 50s and 60s. And for every person getting married at 31, there is somebody getting divorced at 40. You know, in some cases, I actually think this is the
天哪，多么奢侈，却不意识到幕后有多少内部纠纷，有多少人有时感到被排斥，有多少次那些同样的人仍然感到非常、非常孤独。所以这是你在比较时必须意识到的另一件事。婚姻怎么样？所以关于婚姻和关系以及我们的相对常态与，就像我们的感知与现实。再次，使用英国数据，一个人第一次结婚的平均年龄是31岁。在90年代，哦，抱歉，在70年代是23岁。那只是开始。对于每个25岁结婚的人，都有另一个人在35岁或40岁或50多岁和60多岁时结婚。而且对于每个31岁结婚的人，都有人在40岁时离婚。你知道，在某些情况下，我实际上认为这是
norm now. I think we say it's like 50% of people end up getting divorced. I think it's around 42% now. Like 42% of marriage is end in divorce. There is a statistically significant portion of people who are entering into an engagement or a marriage in their 20s, who look like they have everything together, who further down the line are going to realize they were with the wrong person. And so if you are feeling like that is really far off from you, you've got to remember your own timeline is like absolutely fine. And you might actually be saving yourself from a lot of grief. Dr. Meg Jay, who we know and love, she's the author of The Defining Decade. We had her on the podcast. When she was on the podcast, she said something really interesting.
现在的常态。我想我们说大约50%的人最终离婚。我想现在大约是42%。就像42%的婚姻以离婚告终。有统计学上显著比例的人在20多岁时进入订婚或婚姻，看起来他们拥有一切，但在以后会意识到他们和错误的人在一起。所以如果你觉得那离你很远，你必须记住你自己的时间表是绝对没问题的。而且你实际上可能正在从很多悲伤中拯救自己。梅格·杰伊博士，我们认识并喜爱她，她是《决定性十年》的作者。我们请她上过播客。当她在播客上时，她说了一些非常有趣的话。
which is that from her experience, so many 20-somethings get in touch with her and they feel like they're behind. And the thing she always says is that this is your training will decade. And what you think is behind is actually saving you from so much. Our 20s aren't about getting everything done. They're about getting things started. They're about experimenting. If you've done everything you wanted to do in your 20s, everything you ever wanted to do in life in your 20s, what would the rest of your life before. So when you take stock of your life, please remember to include that more global, wider perspective of what the average of things is actually in reality, not just what you expect from yourself, not just thinking that what the average is is what you want
那就是根据她的经验，很多20多岁的人联系她，他们觉得他们落后了。而她总是说的是，这是你的训练十年。而你认为落后的东西实际上正在从很多事情中拯救你。我们的20多岁不是关于完成所有事情。它们是关于开始事情。它们是关于实验。如果你在20多岁时完成了你想做的一切，你在20多岁时生活中一直想做的一切，你余生会做什么。所以当你盘点你的生活时，请记住包括那个更全球、更广泛的视角，即事物的平均值在现实中到底是什么，不仅仅是你对自己期望什么，不仅仅是认为平均值就是你想要的
from your life. So to kind of summarize these points, you're not as behind us you think because you are only comparing yourself to allies. You are not as behind as you think because you are misconstruing envy as a negative emotion when it could be a powerful force, and you are not as behind as you think because you're not looking globally. The fourth reason that you are not as behind as you think is also a perspective issue, and it's about something that we know of and we call the social clock. The social clock is a concept that was first introduced by the psychologist Bernice Newgarten all the way back in the 60s. And when Bernice introduced this idea, She basically suggested that a lot of our behavior is unconsciously controlled primarily by a social rather than a biological clock.
从你的生活中。所以，为了总结这些观点，你并没有你想象中那么落后，因为你只是在拿自己和盟友做比较。你并没有你想象中那么落后，因为你误把嫉妒当成了一种负面情绪，而它本可以是一种强大的力量；你也没有你想象中那么落后，因为你没有从全球视角来看待问题。你觉得自己落后的第四个原因也是一个视角问题，它关乎我们所熟知的一个概念，即“社会时钟”。社会时钟是一个由心理学家伯尼斯·纽加滕（Bernice Neugarten）早在60年代提出的概念。当伯尼斯提出这个想法时，她基本上暗示，我们的许多行为在潜意识里主要是受社会时钟而非生物时钟控制的。
And also rather than our own desires, our life is controlled by what we think we should be doing based on what other people expect. We seem to have this idea on our minds of like when we can and when we can't do things or when we should and we shouldn't do things based on our age. And it's fundamentally driven by social norms that indoctrinate this certain appropriate timeline for. life that's actually kind of bullshit. You know, you might hear people saying things like, I'm just too old to be living at home. I'm too old to go back to school. I'm too old to try that. I'm too young to apply for a job like this. Somebody my age should be married by now. Somebody my age should have had their first relationship. If I don't have a kid by this age, I'm never going to. Like that one maybe, but the rest of them, like, where did this idea come from?
而且，我们的生活并非由我们自己的欲望所主导，而是由我们认为自己应该做什么（基于他人的期望）所控制。我们脑海中似乎有一种观念，即基于年龄，我们什么时候可以做某事，什么时候不可以，或者什么时候应该做某事，什么时候不应该。这从根本上是由社会规范驱动的，这些规范灌输了一种特定的、所谓的“适当”人生时间表，但这其实有点扯淡。你知道，你可能会听到人们说：“我这么大年纪还住家里，太老了”、“我太老了，不能回去上学了”、“我太老了，不敢尝试那个”、“我太年轻了，不能申请这样的工作”、“像我这个年纪的人早该结婚了”、“像我这个年纪的人早该谈过第一次恋爱了”。“如果我到了这个年纪还没孩子，我就永远不会有了。”最后那个可能还有点道理，但其他的呢？这些想法到底是从哪儿来的？
How do we learn to be so constrained by age? And additionally, with like the biological clock thing as well, like we have these ideas that like if I don't have a kid by like 35, like I'm basically barren. People like have kids in their 50s these days. Like you are not as constrained by biology as you think. So the first thing to know is that the social clock, not the biological clock, we're back to the social clock, is culturally specific. This was demonstrated in this study published in the journal.
我们是如何学会被年龄如此束缚的？此外，关于生物时钟的问题，我们也有这样的想法，比如“如果我到35岁还没孩子，我基本上就没法生育了”。但如今人们在50多岁时生孩子的情况也很多。你并没有你想象中那样受生物学限制。所以，首先要明白的是，社会时钟（不是生物时钟，我们回到社会时钟）是具有文化特异性的。这一点在发表于某期刊的一项研究中得到了证实。
I think it would have been like the social psychology bulletin or social psychology journal. And it looked at the way that cultural beliefs impact the social clock in China and the US. Specifically, what they wanted to figure out was what were the earliest and the latest ages, people in both places, thought it was appropriate to engage in several life events. So things like getting married, having a kid, starting a career. They wanted to show that the social clock that we think is universal is really just cultural. They found that the time windows were much different. So in the US, people felt like they had a much, much larger window to complete certain
我想那应该是《社会心理学公报》或《社会心理学期刊》。它研究了文化信仰如何影响中国和美国的社会时钟。具体来说，他们想弄清楚的是，在这两个地方，人们认为进行几项人生大事（如结婚、生子、开始职业生涯）的最早和最晚年龄分别是多少。他们想证明，我们认为普世的社会时钟实际上只是文化产物。他们发现时间窗口差异很大。在美国，人们觉得他们有非常、非常大的窗口期来完成某些
milestones like getting married and having a baby and figuring themselves out. And in China, that window was narrower. The rigidity or flexibility of the window, whether it could be moved or not really, influenced the individual's experience of milestone anxiety and the individual's experience of being behind. And what they found was that, even without any... really needing to say anything. When people fell outside these windows where they felt things were appropriate to do or not do, they seem to like fundamentally have this sense of like being
里程碑，比如结婚、生子和自我探索。而在中国，这个窗口期更窄。窗口期的僵化或灵活性（即它是否可以移动）确实影响了个人对里程碑的焦虑感，以及个人觉得自己落后的体验。他们发现，即使不需要任何人说什么，当人们落在这些他们认为“适当”或“不适当”的窗口之外时，他们似乎从根本上产生了一种
off time. Without anybody really needing to say anything, it was so indoctrinated. What's interesting, though, is that they also found, well, this was a separate study, the majority of people don't abide by the social clock anyway. That's because the social clock is meant to be corrective. It's meant to be punishing and preventative, I guess, rather than helpful. it is actually not the norm. It doesn't necessarily describe what most people are actually doing. It describes what we think culturally a person should be doing. And then it gives us a way to judge ourselves when our lives don't match up with those expectations. The social clock, specifically, I think, what it does is that it convinces us that age is evidence and that we age
“错位”感。不需要任何人说什么，这种观念已经根深蒂固了。然而有趣的是，他们还发现（好吧，这是另一项研究），大多数人其实并不遵守社会时钟。这是因为社会时钟旨在起到纠正作用。我想，它更多是惩罚性和预防性的，而不是有益的。它实际上并不是常态。它并不一定描述大多数人真正在做的事情，它描述的是我们文化上认为一个人“应该”做什么。然后，当我们的生活与这些期望不符时，它给了我们一种评判自己的方式。社会时钟，我特别认为，它所做的是让我们相信年龄就是证据，并且我们以
and mature and identical ways. Age is evidence of where we should be. Age is actually just information about how long you've been alive for. It's literally just a way of measuring time and measuring maybe health. Age cannot tell you whether you are ready for marriage. The age you are does not determine your emotional maturity. Your age does not give you evidence that the right career is, like just because your 22 doesn't mean your career is right or wrong that you should know. Like age does not predict or tell you like what is right for you. It's just how old you are. The reason you are feeling behind is because you see age as the biggest determinant of what you should or shouldn't be doing yet. And the thing is, is that people
相同的方式变老和成熟。年龄是关于我们应该处于什么位置的证据。但年龄实际上只是关于你活了多久的信息。它字面上只是一种衡量时间、或许衡量健康的方式。年龄不能告诉你你是否准备好结婚了。你的年龄并不能决定你的情感成熟度。你的年龄不能证明什么是正确的职业——仅仅因为你22岁，并不意味着你的职业是对是错，或者你应该知道什么。年龄并不能预测或告诉你什么对你来说是正确的。它只是你有多大。你感到落后的原因是因为你把年龄视为你应该或不应该做什么的最大决定因素。问题是，人们
have been disproving the belief that there is a certain timeline that makes people happy for so long. Like some of the happiest people alive got married at 60. They didn't find a job they loved until they were 50. Because our 20s and life in general is defined by this lack of definition, I think we crave anything that can add structure or definition back into our lives. And that blueprint that is provided by the social clock just seems to be the easiest thing to grab onto. If I live my life exactly according to this plan, society has said that I would be happy. I actually don't think it's that helpful and I actually don't think it's the guarantee for happiness that we think it is. I think if you are finding yourself victim to the social clock,
长期以来一直在反驳那种“存在某种能让人幸福的时间表”的信念。比如，一些最幸福的人是在60岁才结婚的。他们直到50岁才找到自己热爱的工作。因为我们的20多岁以及生活本身是由这种缺乏定义所定义的，我认为我们渴望任何能为生活增加结构或定义的东西。而社会时钟提供的蓝图似乎是最容易抓住的东西。如果我完全按照这个计划生活，社会说我会幸福。我实际上认为这并没有多大帮助，而且我也不认为它是我们所认为的幸福保证。如果你发现自己是社会时钟的受害者，
go searching for all the people who haven't abided by this timeline and have yet still found extreme joy and extreme happiness. Because I actually think it's most people. Also, perhaps observe, if you want, the people who have abided by the timeline. Do they seem happier to you? No, I actually don't think they do, because life is so much more nuanced than that. There is no guaranteed formula that if you do things this way, you will be happy. There is a socially prescriptive formula, but, yeah, as I said, I don't know about you.
去寻找那些没有遵守这个时间表却依然找到了极致快乐和幸福的人吧。因为我实际上认为那是大多数人。此外，如果你愿意，也可以观察一下那些遵守了时间表的人。他们看起来更幸福吗？不，我实际上认为他们并不幸福，因为生活比那要微妙得多。没有一种保证的公式说如果你这样做，你就会幸福。确实存在一种社会规定的公式，但是，正如我所说，我不知道你怎么看。
I encounter slash I see a lot of people in my life, in my family, like just in general, who have done everything by the book, and they don't seem to really be enjoying themselves. So just bear that in mind next time you feel like if I'd done it this way, maybe I'd be more happy. It's the classic grasses greener on the other side dilemma. So my next reason why you may not be as behind as you think is much more psychological. and I think it's a reality. I don't think.
我在生活中、在我的家庭中，或者在一般情况下，遇到/看到很多人，他们一切都按部就班，但他们似乎并没有真正享受生活。所以，下次当你觉得“如果我按这种方式做，也许我会更幸福”时，请记住这一点。这就是经典的“邻家草坪更绿”的困境。所以，你可能并没有你想象中那么落后的下一个原因更具心理学色彩，而且我认为这是一个现实。我不认为……
I know it's a reality that a lot of you have experienced and may still be living that you just don't acknowledge or give yourself credit for. You have spent a great deal of your life in survival mode and you are now comparing your progress to someone's end goal, not accounting for all the things that you had to survive
我知道这是一个现实，你们中的许多人都经历过，并且可能仍在经历，只是你们没有承认或给予自己应有的认可。你生命中的很大一部分时间都在“生存模式”中度过，而你现在却在拿自己的进步与别人的最终目标进行比较，却没有考虑到你必须经历的所有事情，
and you had to endure and you had to get through, which they probably do, didn't. And they perhaps did not have to do or survive or endure. You are not giving yourself enough credit for the fact that your start line was different to everyone else's. It's not about making excuses for yourself. I know a lot of people feel very opposed to that. I really just think it's about having grace towards your environment and to the fact that not everybody's environment and start line was the same. We spent a lot of time talking about privilege on this podcast and
你必须忍受并克服的事情，而他们可能并没有经历过。他们或许不必去做、去生存或去忍受。你没有给予自己足够的认可，因为你的起跑线与其他人不同。这不是在为自己找借口。我知道很多人对此非常反感。我真的只是认为，这关乎对你的环境保持宽容，并承认并非每个人的环境和起跑线都是一样的。我们在本播客中花了很多时间讨论特权，
talking about things like financial inheritance and money and how people are better set off if their parents were making more and if their parents had a good education and their parents had a good job. Huge advantages. Those are massive advantages. However, I think one of the greatest gifts we can receive that a lot of us don't is a strong emotional inheritance from our parents and from our support system. It is the gift of a loving home, a loving support system that arms us with the belief that like we can really step into the world and we can be resilient and optimistic and like if something goes wrong there is somebody who is going to help us with that problem a lot of people don't have that and when we don't have that and we feel like we're really
讨论诸如经济遗产和金钱之类的事情，以及如果父母赚得更多、受过良好教育、有份好工作，人们的起点会更好。巨大的优势。那些是巨大的优势。然而，我认为我们能收到的最伟大的礼物之一（很多人没有得到）是来自父母和支持系统的强大情感遗产。这是一份充满爱的家庭、充满爱的支持系统的礼物，它武装了我们，让我们相信我们可以真正步入世界，我们可以变得坚韧和乐观，如果出了问题，有人会帮我们解决那个问题。很多人没有这种支持，当我们没有这种支持，并且觉得我们真的
on our own we expend a lot more resources just trying to feel secure and trying to feel safe and we expend those resources like we just have to really deal with that before we can turn our mind towards our actual like ambitious true dreams. Like your dream is just to get through this. Other people's dreams who aren't going through this is to like, I want to be a millionaire. I want to do all that. I want to be an artist. You don't, you haven't had the time for that yet. So what actually puts us in survival mode? A lot of things, it can be everything from emotional neglect to experiencing a family breakdown at a young age, chronic trauma, grief at a young age, mental or physical illness at a young age, a natural disaster, having to immigrate, moving around
孤身一人时，我们为了感到安全和保障，会消耗更多的资源，我们消耗这些资源，就像我们必须先处理好这些，才能把心思转向我们真正雄心勃勃的梦想。比如，你的梦想只是为了熬过去。而那些没有经历这些的人，他们的梦想是“我想成为百万富翁，我想做所有那些事，我想成为一名艺术家”。你还没有时间去想这些。那么，到底是什么让我们进入了生存模式？很多事情，从情感忽视到年轻时经历家庭破裂、长期创伤、年轻时经历丧亲之痛、年轻时患有精神或身体疾病、自然灾害、不得不移民、频繁搬家，
a lot, anything that disrupts our emotional and physical equilibrium, or like sense of homeostasis, can send an internal message from an early time in our lives that we are not safe. And when we don't feel safe, we don't have the mental resources to focus on flourishing. Flourishing and surviving are opposed. On the outside, if you are somebody who has been in this survival state or in survival mode for a while, yeah, your life might seem really, really normal. You actually might have a really great job and you might have a really great partner and really good friends. You might be a really, really amazing at hiding this part of you and compartmentalizing and functioning very well.
任何破坏我们情感和身体平衡或“稳态感”的事情，都可能从我们生命早期就发出一种内部信息，即我们是不安全的。当我们感到不安全时，我们就没有心理资源去专注于“繁荣”。繁荣和生存是相对的。从外表上看，如果你是一个长期处于这种生存状态或生存模式的人，是的，你的生活看起来可能非常、非常正常。你实际上可能有一份很棒的工作，有一个很棒的伴侣和很好的朋友。你可能非常、非常擅长隐藏这一面，进行心理隔离并运作得很好。
That can make it hard for others to recognize. It can also make it hard for ourselves to recognize that we are still struggling things that are making life harder. But deep down, like, there is a much different picture here. Like, you might think I'm doing really well. But when you are in survival mode, your brain and your body is just hijacked by the sympathetic nervous system. It is hijacked by a continuous hypervigilance and a continuous fight or flight response, which makes you feel constantly on edge.
这可能让别人很难察觉。这也可能让我们自己很难意识到我们仍在挣扎，那些让生活变得更艰难的事情。但在内心深处，这里有一幅完全不同的画面。比如，你可能认为我做得很好。但当你处于生存模式时，你的大脑和身体只是被交感神经系统劫持了。它被持续的过度警觉和持续的“战斗或逃跑”反应所劫持，这让你感到时刻处于边缘。
Your body, it's not constantly being flooded with cortisol and adrenaline the way that we imagine, but there is always a low level of tension. Even when it comes to like neurological activity, like, and the energy that you can put into certain thought processes, you don't have time for that. Your prefrontal lobe is already planning and redirecting and trying to figure out something else. And your fear center is overriding all of its plans anyways. It's harder to function.
你的身体并不是像我们想象的那样不断被皮质醇和肾上腺素淹没，但总有一种低水平的紧张感。即使是神经活动，以及你可以投入到某些思维过程中的能量，你也没有时间去处理。你的前额叶已经在计划、重定向并试图弄清楚其他事情。而你的恐惧中心无论如何都在覆盖它所有的计划。运作起来更难了。
Those in survival mode may feel very emotionally numb. there's physical symptoms, there's fatigue, and then there's just this feeling of like, how come I can't organize my thoughts and make sense of my life like other people can? Because you've got so much in your mind. It can also warp our perception of time and really cause it to feel either hyper-accelerated or painfully slow, and that itself contributes to that feeling that we are behind explicitly. For example, there was one study in 2015 by researchers in the UK, and they found that people who have experienced trauma, specifically events that have led us to have a loss of trust
那些处于生存模式的人可能会感到非常情感麻木。有身体症状，有疲劳感，还有一种感觉，比如“为什么我不能像其他人那样组织我的思想并理清我的生活？”因为你的脑子里装了太多东西。它还会扭曲我们对时间的感知，并真正导致它感觉要么被极度加速，要么慢得令人痛苦，而这本身就导致了我们明显感到落后的感觉。例如，2015年英国研究人员进行了一项研究，他们发现经历过创伤的人，特别是那些导致我们对世界失去信任
or confidence in the world, people who have experienced this are more likely to encounter a phenomenon known as a sense of foreshortened future. A sense of foreshortened future is essentially the feeling that your future does not exist. If you have gone through trauma or something really hard, you may find that it's really hard, really difficult to like imagine yourself getting married, imagine yourself happy, imagine yourself at 50. Think about what that does to your ability to feel like you are progressing through life. It is incredibly difficult to build towards a future that your brain actually does not acknowledge and does not believe exists because it's just shut that off. You know, other people are able to make five-year plans and they're able to take risks and they
或信心的人，更有可能遇到一种被称为“未来缩短感”的现象。未来缩短感本质上是一种感觉，即你的未来不存在。如果你经历过创伤或非常艰难的事情，你可能会发现很难想象自己结婚、想象自己幸福、想象自己50岁的样子。想想这对你感觉自己正在经历人生有什么影响。建立一个你的大脑实际上并不承认、也不相信其存在的未来是极其困难的，因为它已经关闭了那个功能。你知道，其他人能够制定五年计划，他们能够承担风险，他们
they understand that investing is probably worthwhile because, yeah, of course they're going to be alive at 50 to use that money and they understand the importance of long-term goals. For you, no, survival mode keeps your attention anchored to what is happening right now. So what needs fixing? What could go wrong? What do I need to get through today? The long-term planning is not a priority. It's not a priority until one day, maybe you exit survival mode and you look up and you realize,
他们明白投资可能是值得的，因为，是的，当然他们到50岁时还活着可以使用那笔钱，他们明白长期目标的重要性。对你来说，不，生存模式让你的注意力锚定在当下正在发生的事情上。所以需要修复什么？什么可能出错？我今天需要熬过什么？长期规划不是优先事项。直到有一天，也许你退出了生存模式，你抬头看，你意识到，
oh, wait a second, wait a second. I didn't, I don't think I got the same memo as everybody. else. Like, why didn't I do all these planning things? Like, why do I feel so behind? This is where you need to show yourself some unconditional grace, unconditional compassion, as much of those things as you have available to you, you were living on a shorter psychological timeline. Your brain literally did not imagine the future. You had other priorities. Your nervous system was constantly making you hypervigilant, unable to think about flourishing or fulfillment. And I think you need to give yourself credit for the fact that
哦，等一下，等一下。我不认为我收到了和大家一样的备忘录。比如，为什么我没有做所有这些规划的事情？比如，为什么我感到如此落后？这就是你需要对自己表现出无条件的宽容、无条件的同情的地方，尽可能多地给予自己这些东西。你生活在一个更短的心理时间轴上。你的大脑字面上没有想象未来。你有其他的优先事项。你的神经系统不断让你过度警觉，无法思考繁荣或成就感。而且我认为你需要为以下事实给予自己认可：
that you've accomplished so much just by enduring and surviving that. In my eyes, that's an achievement in itself. I know that's a complicated feeling. I do think it's an achievement. Your emotional and psychological resume is stacked. Even if your professional resume or career resume isn't where you would like it to be, your psychological resume sorted. I also think it's never too late to start over and to start planning and to try again,
你仅仅通过忍受和生存下来就已经完成了这么多。在我看来，这本身就是一种成就。我知道这是一种复杂的感觉。我确实认为这是一种成就。你的情感和心理简历非常丰富。即使你的职业简历或事业简历没有达到你想要的程度，你的心理简历也已经整理好了。我也认为重新开始、重新规划和再次尝试永远都不晚，
but also try again for the first time. but truly, please, if you resonate with this right now, I need you to know, like, I just so desperately want to impress upon you that in my eyes, and I think in many other people's eyes, like, you were not behind. If the start line was here, everybody else was starting from that point, and you just had to, you got dropped at the wrong location. You were all the way back there. You've already run like a whole other race before you have started the race that the majority of people are now enduring. So please have some kindness towards yourself. Okay, I want to talk about the final two reasons you are not as behind as you think and some advice for when you still feel
但也请第一次尝试再次尝试。但真的，拜托，如果你现在对此有共鸣，我需要你知道，我只是非常绝望地想让你明白，在我看来，而且我认为在许多其他人看来，你并没有落后。如果起跑线在这里，其他人都是从那个点开始的，而你只是被扔在了错误的位置。你一直在后面。在你开始大多数人现在正在经历的比赛之前，你已经跑完了另一场完整的比赛。所以请对自己好一点。好的，我想谈谈你并没有你想象中那么落后的最后两个原因，以及当你仍然感到
that way after this short break. The music you love. Your favorite radio stations. Everywhere you go. The podcasts everyone's talking about. All in one place. And it's free. High heart radio. Whatever you want to hear. Listen anytime. Anywhere. Music, radio, podcasts, unlimited audio.
那样时的一些建议，在短暂休息之后。你喜爱的音乐。你最喜欢的广播电台。无论你走到哪里。每个人都在谈论的播客。都在同一个地方。而且它是免费的。iHeart Radio。无论你想听什么。随时随地收听。音乐、广播、播客，无限音频。
It's on the free IHurt Radio app. Let's go! One app, no subscription. Always free. Grab the free app. I heart radio. Everywhere you go. Always free.
它在免费的iHeart Radio应用程序上。我们走吧！一个应用程序，无需订阅。永远免费。获取免费应用程序。iHeart Radio。无论你走到哪里。永远免费。
Download the free IHR radio app today. Lisa, we should tell them about our new show. Oh my God, Lexi. We have a new podcast. It's called Don't Lie to Me. I'm Lexi You Want You. We're two best friends, 22 years apart, but so close at heart.
立即下载免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。Lisa，我们应该告诉他们我们的新节目。天哪，Lexi。我们有一个新的播客。它叫《别对我撒谎》（Don't Lie to Me）。我是Lexi You Want You。我们是两个最好的朋友，相差22岁，但心却如此贴近。
And I'm Lisa Di Giulio, the old one, which means we have wildly different references, occasionally different opinions, and at this point in my 50s, I've lived it all. I'm not going to get anyone fighting. That is wild. I learned that about you today. Now in my 30s, being the founder of new shoes,
我是Lisa Di Giulio，年长的那位，这意味着我们有截然不同的参考点，偶尔有不同的观点，而且在我50多岁的这个时候，我已经经历了一切。我不会让任何人吵架。这太疯狂了。我今天才了解到关于你的这一点。现在我30多岁，作为新鞋的创始人，
good taste is my business, and I've always got something to say. If men were just honest about this, there would be so much more peace in the world. We're going to talk about dates, relationships, beauty, getting older, and a little wiser. We're best friends, but we don't always agree. Because you told us how accommodating you are.
好品味是我的生意，我总是有话要说。如果男人们对此诚实一点，世界会和平得多。我们将谈论约会、关系、美丽、变老，以及变得更聪明一点。我们是最好的朋友，但我们并不总是同意对方。因为你告诉我们你有多么随和。
Obviously, I would do what I think I could do to fight the fight, but there's only so much fight I can fight. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me.
显然，我会尽我所能去战斗，但战斗也是有限度的。《别对我撒谎》。《别对我撒谎》。《别对我撒谎》。《别对我撒谎》。《别对我撒谎》。《别对我撒谎》。
Liar. Listen on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I don't really care. I'm Lacey Mosley. author, actor, stand-up comedian, creator, and host of Scam Goddess Podcasts, the True Crime Comedy Podcasts, all about robbery, fraud, and those who practice it. Each week I bring on incredible guests like Conan O'Brien, Iowa Debrie, Lamorne Morris, and Nicole Beyer. Ooh, I scammed them.
骗子。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。我真的不在乎。我是Lacey Mosley。作家、演员、单口喜剧演员、创作者，也是《Scam Goddess》播客的主持人，这是一个关于抢劫、欺诈和那些实践者们的真实犯罪喜剧播客。每周我都会邀请像Conan O'Brien、Ayo Edebiri、Lamorne Morris和Nicole Byer这样不可思议的嘉宾。噢，我骗了他们。
I could talk to you for a hour. You're a generational yapper like me. That's why I had to make yapping a job. And the scams run the gamut. I'm talking about scams from the 1800s all the way up to today. I also warn you and keep you safe against scammers. Call your grandparents. Tell your parents to stop clicking on links, please. And now you can catch full episodes of my show on YouTube. If there's a scam, I'm here to protect you. And I'm also here to laugh with you. So if you like fun, if you like comedy, and you like learning and protecting yourself from criminals, start listening to scam goddess on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
我可以和你聊一个小时。你和我一样是那种滔滔不绝的人。这就是为什么我必须把“滔滔不绝”变成一份工作。而且骗局五花八门。我说的是从1800年代一直到今天的骗局。我还警告你并保护你免受骗子的伤害。给你的祖父母打电话。请告诉你的父母停止点击链接。现在你可以在YouTube上观看我节目的完整剧集。如果有骗局，我在这里保护你。我也在这里和你一起笑。所以如果你喜欢乐趣，如果你喜欢喜剧，并且你喜欢学习并保护自己免受罪犯的伤害，开始在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Scam Goddess》吧。
Hi, this is Kylie Breakman. Angel Geratana. Jeremy Colhane. Patrick McDonald. And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists Podcast. The Improvised Character Comedy Podcast where each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft. Join us for a panel of wellness influencers. What I try to do is faux journal.
嗨，我是Kylie Brakeman。Angel Geratana。Jeremy Culhane。Patrick McDonald。我们是《Artists on Artists on Artists》播客的主持人。这是一个即兴角色喜剧播客，每周都有一个新的艺术家小组讨论他们的手艺。加入我们，参加一个健康影响者小组。我尝试做的是伪日记。
I don't know. Have you guys heard of faux journaling? Yeah, it's reading. It's called reading. So we don't like to use that word anymore. A panel of New Yorker cartoonists. Have you guys? done Terry Gross's Peloton class.
我不知道。你们听说过伪日记吗？是的，那是阅读。它叫阅读。所以我们不再喜欢用那个词了。《纽约客》漫画家小组。你们做过Terry Gross的Peloton课程吗？
No! I've been dying too. I'm so sorry. I'm seeing a reading of Sadako in the Thousand Paper Cranes by Audra McDonald's at the Wonderland Bookstore on 14th. That's crazy. I went to the Wonderland bookstore yesterday and I heard Nora Jones do a reading of Zero Dark 30. No way.
没有！我一直想做。我很抱歉。我正在第14街的Wonderland书店观看Audra McDonald朗读《Sadako and the Thousand Paper Cranes》。那太疯狂了。我昨天去了Wonderland书店，听到Nora Jones朗读《Zero Dark Thirty》。不会吧。
You have to come to the last bookstore though. Kim Cottrell is reading the guitar tabs of yesterday. A panel of Eurovision participants. And we do a little Halloween sometime. Does the Pope dress up? He winks on Halloween. It's right up next to the microphone.
你必须去最后一家书店。Kim Cattrall正在朗读《Yesterday》的吉他谱。欧洲歌唱大赛参赛者小组。我们有时会做一点万圣节活动。教皇会打扮吗？他在万圣节眨眼。就在麦克风旁边。
I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween. Listen to artists on artists on artists on artists on the IHeard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. By age 11 or so, at least 70% have a phone. Middle school is a different world than the one we grew up in. I'm Dr. Joy, and this is therapy for black girls. We spent real time on it in our surviving middle school run, bringing in a child psychologist and a psychiatrist who's raising two black girls of his own to talk about what's really going on
我听说你几乎能听到睫毛撞击的声音。你从未见过意大利像教皇在万圣节起床眨眼时那样安静。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Artists on Artists on Artists》。到11岁左右，至少70%的孩子有手机。初中是一个与我们成长时期完全不同的世界。我是Joy博士，这是《Therapy for Black Girls》。我们在“生存初中”系列中花了很多时间，请来了一位儿童心理学家和一位正在抚养两个黑人女孩的精神科医生，来谈谈现在我们孩子身上到底发生了什么
with our kids right now. So it's literally physiological and neurological and psychological and psychological chaos happening all this end up. We got into group chats and gaming, friendships and bullying, and how to tell the difference between healthy monitoring and the kind of surveillance that erodes trust. And belonging, you could think of belonging as I can be more. myself and I can still be accepted, and then there's fitting in. Spitting in says I have to change who I am in order to avoid rejection. Then we turn the conversation toward the fathers, sitting down
所以这简直是生理、神经、心理和心理上的混乱。我们讨论了群聊和游戏、友谊和欺凌，以及如何区分健康的监控和那种侵蚀信任的监视。还有归属感，你可以把归属感看作“我可以做我自己，我仍然可以被接受”，然后是“融入”。融入意味着“为了避免被拒绝，我必须改变我是谁”。然后我们将对话转向父亲们，与治疗师Keir Gaines坐下来
with therapist Keir Gaines on Black fatherhood and what it means to raise a daughter through this stage. You don't have on shorts, so you can't do flips, you have on the dressy, up across your legs. That's the range of this run, from screen time to identity to the father's doing the work at home. We have to get off her device, but the reality is there's a lot of life out there that we don't want you as your adults in their life to miss out on. This has been our surviving middle school run. Brought to you by the people who spend their careers thinking about exactly this. I'm Dr. Joy.
讨论黑人父亲身份，以及在这个阶段抚养女儿意味着什么。你没穿短裤，所以你不能做后空翻，你穿的是裙子，交叉双腿。这就是这个系列的范围，从屏幕时间到身份，再到在家工作的父亲们。我们必须让她离开设备，但现实是，外面有很多生活，我们不希望你们作为他们生活中的成年人错过。这就是我们的“生存初中”系列。由那些职业生涯都在思考这个问题的人带给你。我是Joy博士。
Listen to therapy for black girls on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. So before the break, we talked about survival mode. In my opinion, I actually think more and more of us are encountering this survival state these days outside of childhood. yes, because of childhood trauma or childhood experiences, but also because life is actually just getting a lot harder. And I do think the bar for surviving is just, I don't think, I feel like I know this, it's just been raised significantly. Like, this wouldn't be, this wouldn't be like
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Therapy for Black Girls》。所以在休息之前，我们谈到了生存模式。在我看来，我实际上认为我们中越来越多的人在童年之外也遇到了这种生存状态。是的，因为童年创伤或童年经历，但也因为生活实际上变得越来越难了。而且我确实认为生存的门槛被显著提高了。就像，这不会是……这不会是……
a proper episode about why we feel behind if we didn't acknowledge the fact that the world we have inherited is to put it lightly, a bit of a shit show. It just, it's just, it's just, it's just, just not going great. So much of what we've talked about in this episode, milestone anxiety, the social clock, comparison. It's partly because an older generation dictated what should be possible based on experiences that we can no longer afford and based on a world that no longer exists. And that is the standard we are measuring ourselves too. Housing is really expensive. Grad jobs feel non-existent. Everything close. costs more. So when your soul focus is now, how in the world I'm actually going to afford to live,
关于为什么我们感到落后的适当一集，如果我们不承认我们继承的世界，委婉地说，是一团糟的话。它只是……它只是……它只是……它只是……它只是不太好。我们在这一集中谈论的很多内容，里程碑焦虑、社会时钟、比较。部分原因是老一辈人根据我们无法再负担的经历和不再存在的世界，规定了什么是可能的。而这就是我们衡量自己的标准。住房非常昂贵。毕业后的工作似乎不存在。一切都在涨价。所以当你的核心焦点现在是“我到底该如何负担生活”时，
bigger dreams and bigger ambitions do get put on hold, and therefore so does a more meaningful version or feeling of progress. There are two psychology terms you should know that describe this really, really well, and describe why this is making you feel behind or fall behind. The first is a well-known one. It's the idea of a scarcity mindset. And the second is less one. known, it's called the cognitive bandwidth tax. They're very much related and they are very much impacting us whilst we encounter this world that feels very difficult to be in. To begin with, let's talk about the scarcity mindset. So put simply, a scarcity mindset occurs when our preoccupation with a lack of resources means that we make irrational decisions. I often talk about
更大的梦想和更大的抱负确实会被搁置，因此更有意义的进步感或感觉也会被搁置。有两个你应该知道的心理学术语，它们很好地描述了这一点，并描述了为什么这让你感到落后或掉队。第一个是众所周知的。它是“稀缺心态”的概念。第二个不太为人所知，它被称为“认知带宽税”。它们非常相关，并且在我们遇到这个感觉非常难以生存的世界时，它们正在极大地影响我们。首先，让我们谈谈稀缺心态。简单来说，稀缺心态发生在我们对资源匮乏的关注意味着我们做出非理性决定时。我经常谈论
this with regards to dating. You probably heard it in a dating episode, but in this context when you get in a rut or a spiral and you start imagining that you're never going to meet anyone and there's really no good fish left in the sea, this often means that we end up settling for less because we don't have that rort of view of abundance or a sense of possibility when it comes to love. The same applies to all other choices that we make in life. The scarcity mindset is quite universal in that way. If you feel like jobs are scarce, you're not going to take big risks and you're not going to feel like progress is happening. If you feel like money is scarce, you're not going to invest, you're not going to feel like
这一点，关于约会。你可能在约会那一集中听到过，但在这种情况下，当你陷入困境或螺旋式下降，开始想象你永远不会遇到任何人，海里真的没有好鱼了，这通常意味着我们最终会妥协，因为我们没有那种关于爱的丰盛感或可能性感。同样的情况也适用于我们在生活中做出的所有其他选择。稀缺心态在某种程度上是相当普遍的。如果你觉得工作稀缺，你就不会承担大的风险，也不会觉得进步正在发生。如果你觉得钱稀缺，你就不会投资，你就不会觉得
progress is being made towards your savings. If you feel like it's going to take longer to find a career you love, you're not going to take a gap year, you're not going to take time off, you're not actually going to explore interest, you're not going to feel like there is this progress towards having a fulfilling life. The very real sense of scarcity that we are feeling right now because of the state of the world blocks our ability to be ambitious and build better long-term goals that require sacrifices now, or long-term rewards. We don't make those sacrifices now because we don't believe those sacrifices will pay off considering the state of everything.
在储蓄方面取得了进步。如果你觉得找到自己热爱的职业需要更长的时间，你就不会休间隔年，你不会休息，你实际上不会探索兴趣，你不会觉得在拥有充实生活方面有这种进步。由于世界现状，我们现在感受到的非常真实的稀缺感阻碍了我们雄心勃勃并建立更好的长期目标的能力，这些目标需要现在的牺牲，或者长期的回报。我们现在不做这些牺牲，因为考虑到一切的状态，我们不相信这些牺牲会有回报。
And this is why we feel behind our sense of abundance and what feels possible, both now and in the future, feels restricted. And yet we are comparing ourselves to people for whom that context is not the same. Like, they are not experiencing this in the same way. That second concept I mentioned before is also important. and it's similar to the effect of survival mode. The cognitive bandwidth tax is the idea that I spoke about. It was first proposed by these two researchers at Princeton and MIT.
这就是为什么我们感到落后，我们对丰盛感以及什么是可能的（无论是现在还是未来）的感觉受到了限制。然而，我们却在拿自己与那些环境不同的人进行比较。比如，他们并没有以同样的方式经历这一切。我之前提到的第二个概念也很重要，它类似于生存模式的影响。认知带宽税就是我所说的那个想法。它最初是由普林斯顿大学和麻省理工学院的这两位研究人员提出的。
And they basically realized when we have to constantly worry about our basic needs, our attention becomes so narrowly focused on that one thing. It's sometimes called in psychology, attentional tunneling. And we are just so focused on trying to problem solve that, that everything else in our life becomes secondary. and our progress does become quite stagnated. This is particularly relevant for people in their 20s and 30s today. Like, you can't focus on having it all.
他们基本上意识到，当我们必须不断担心我们的基本需求时，我们的注意力就会变得非常狭窄地集中在那一件事上。在心理学中，这有时被称为“注意力隧道”。我们只是如此专注于试图解决那个问题，以至于我们生活中的其他一切都变得次要了。而我们的进步确实变得相当停滞。这对于今天20多岁和30多岁的人来说尤其相关。比如，你不能专注于拥有一切。
You can't work towards having it all because you need to have a job and you need to find a way to make money. And we are continuously comparing ourselves to a previous version of the world where that was less of a concern, like there was more opportunities. this is probably the most important message in this whole episode. Our perception of what it means to be ahead or what it means to be successful has been skewed in so many ways. The reality of how much it takes to get there is a lot greater and harder. As a result, we are facing increasing anxiety to do with, you know, is this going to work or work out? How am I going to find my
你不能为了拥有一切而努力，因为你需要有一份工作，你需要找到一种赚钱的方法。我们不断地拿自己与过去的世界版本进行比较，那时这方面的担忧较少，比如有更多的机会。这可能是整集中最重要的信息。我们对“领先”意味着什么或“成功”意味着什么的感知在很多方面都被扭曲了。达到目标所需的现实要大得多、难得多。结果，我们面临着越来越多的焦虑，关于“这会奏效吗？”、“我该如何找到我的
path. More of us are feeling behind because what it takes to be ahead is just greater. So when you are drowning under these fears, I want you to remember three critical facts, three critical mindset shifts, three critical things just to remember. Number one, the goal in life is to collect experiences and not to speed through them. There is this level of freedom we experience when we detach from the conceptualization of life as a race and we deeply analyze what is actually important to us and what it actually takes to be happy and what it actually takes for life to be meaningful. All these people who achieve amazing things, like what are they and never really go searching for in the end? Health and love,
道路”。我们中更多的人感到落后，因为领先所需的代价更高。所以当你淹没在这些恐惧中时，我希望你记住三个关键事实，三个关键的心态转变，三个关键的事情要记住。第一，人生的目标是收集经历，而不是匆忙度过。当我们从“生活是一场比赛”的概念中解脱出来，并深入分析什么对我们真正重要、什么才是真正幸福所需的、什么才是生活有意义所需的时，我们会体验到一种自由。所有这些取得惊人成就的人，他们最终从未真正去寻找的是什么？健康和爱，
which are incidentally the things that they have perhaps compromised in their pursuit of success and in their allegiance to this strict timeline and the strict notion of what makes a person. The other thing they end up chasing is experiences. And they end up chasing all these things that are going to make them feel alive. It's why billionaires keep flying to the moon. They keep spending billions and millions of dollars to never age. They have given away all their time to the pursuit of their dreams and now they are trying to make up for it. And we have the luxury of that time and the luxury of those experiences.
顺便说一句，这些可能是他们在追求成功以及效忠于这个严格的时间表和关于“一个人是什么”的严格概念时所妥协的东西。他们最终追求的另一件事是经历。他们最终追求所有那些能让他们感到活着的东西。这就是为什么亿万富翁不断飞向月球。他们不断花费数十亿和数百万美元来永葆青春。他们把所有的时间都奉献给了追求梦想，现在他们正试图弥补。而我们拥有那种时间的奢侈和那些经历的奢侈。
Maybe not flying to the moon. But enjoying ourselves. Like you do not leave this world with accolades or your wealth or your job title. You leave it with experiences and you leave it with the thoughts of the people who loved you. Those are things that you can collect, even if the rest of your life is completely falling apart. Experience and connection are always available, I believe. And I'm not even thinking about good experiences or expensive experiences. Everything is an experience.
也许不是飞向月球。而是享受我们自己。就像你离开这个世界时不会带着荣誉、财富或职位头衔一样。你带着经历离开，你带着爱你的人的想法离开。即使你的余生完全分崩离析，这些也是你可以收集的东西。我相信，经历和联系总是可用的。而且我甚至不是在想好的经历或昂贵的经历。一切都是一种经历。
Everything contains value. There's also this fascinating research that shows how people who experiment more, who try more things who are more open to the novelty and like the ups and downs of life, especially at a younger age, actually end up being better in the long run than people who just like settled down and chose something very quickly because they're better able to actually articulate what they do and don't like. They have more wisdom. They have more of a sense of preference. I think everything, every experience is teaching you something that the easy path, like just may not have. And one day when it's your time, you're going to look back at all these moments that just
一切都包含价值。还有一项迷人的研究表明，那些尝试更多、尝试更多事物、对生活的新奇事物以及起起落落更开放的人（尤其是在年轻时），实际上从长远来看比那些只是安定下来并很快选择某事的人更好，因为他们更能真正表达出他们喜欢和不喜欢什么。他们有更多的智慧。他们有更强的偏好感。我认为一切，每一次经历都在教你一些简单的道路可能没有的东西。有一天，当你的时间到了，你会回顾所有这些时刻，它们只是
felt like really awful and frustrating and you're going to realize it was teaching you a lesson that you would need one day. Like it's all these awful memories I've had from my early 20s. I like look at them now and I'm like, best lesson. So glad I learned that then. This brings me to my second truth. Number two, no one's journey to success is ever linear ever, ever, ever, ever know. The detours are I tend to believe the path. I was watching this podcast from Angela Duckworth. She's the woman who wrote the book Grit. Great book. And the book situated, which just came out. Actually, I've been reading it. And she was talking about how up until the age of 31, she had literally no idea what she wanted to do with her life. And the very fact that she had no idea,
感觉非常糟糕和令人沮丧，你会意识到它在教你有一天会需要的教训。就像我20多岁时经历的所有这些糟糕的记忆。我现在回顾它们，心想：最好的教训。很高兴我当时学到了。这让我谈到了我的第二个真理。第二，没有人的成功之路是线性的，从来没有，从来没有，从来没有。我倾向于相信弯路就是道路。我正在看Angela Duckworth的这个播客。她是写《坚毅》（Grit）那本书的女性。很棒的书。还有那本《Situated》，刚刚出版。实际上，我一直在读它。她谈到直到31岁，她完全不知道自己想用生活做什么。而她完全不知道的事实，
she claims, is what took her to places that she was meant to be in. That ambiguity, like, the story gets filled with what is meant to be there and with meaningfully. things. Every success story you see, every single one, every single person who says I'm happy with where I am, that is a story of a thousand failures. I don't know where I got that quote. I think it's a quote. I don't think I came up with that idea, but I think it's true. It's also an incredible mindset to have in your 20s. My failures count as much as my successes. If you knew that you were 100 failures away from your biggest win yet and from life working out, like you would get out there and you would start freaking failing. And I actually do believe failure is a bit of a numbers game. So if you're
她说，这正是引领她走向命中注定之地的原因。那种模糊感，就像故事被那些命中注定会出现在那里的、有意义的事物所填满。你看到的每一个成功故事，每一个，每一个说“我对现状很满意”的人，那都是由一千次失败堆砌而成的故事。我不知道这句话是从哪儿听来的。我想这应该是一句名言。我不认为这是我想出来的，但我认为它是真的。这也是你在20多岁时应该拥有的绝佳心态。我的失败和我的成功一样重要。如果你知道你距离人生最大的胜利和生活步入正轨只差100次失败，那你就会走出去，开始疯狂地去失败。我确实相信失败在某种程度上是一场数字游戏。所以如果你
feeling behind, maybe you're further ahead on that journey. However you want to say it to yourself or picture it, I think that's important. My final reminder, for this whole episode, I know I'm full of wisdom today, but my final reminder, you have so much more time than you think. Every single time, like I interview someone who is 50 or 60, they always say the same thing to me, which is that in your 20s and 30s, you feel like this is the best it will ever be. you feel like life is already over and it's not. You have literally been an adult for less time than you have been a child. Like if you are 25, you've been an adult for seven years, you were a child for 18 years. Give yourself a little bit of grace. Truly, give yourself some credit for what you've been
感到落后，也许你在那段旅程中其实走得更远。无论你想怎么对自己说，或者怎么去想象，我认为这都很重要。我给这一整集节目的最后提醒——我知道我今天充满了智慧——但我的最后提醒是：你拥有的时间比你想象的要多得多。每一次，当我采访那些50岁或60岁的人时，他们总是对我说同样的话，那就是在20多岁和30多岁时，你会觉得这就是人生最好的时候了。你会觉得生活已经结束了，但事实并非如此。你作为一个成年人的时间，实际上比你作为一个孩子的时间还要短。比如如果你25岁，你做成年人只有7年，而你做孩子有18年。对自己宽容一点。真的，为你所经历的、
through, what you've been challenged by, how much you have done, how much you have achieved, how much you have seen, who you've been. I'm sure the list of what you have actually accomplished it's just much longer than you allow yourself to contemplate. You're being too humble. You're being way too humble. And even if you still feel behind and you look at that list and you're like, oh, God, maybe, like actually, that's still not good. Behind who?
为你所面临的挑战、为你所做的一切、为你所取得的成就、为你所见过的世面、为你曾经成为过的人，给自己一点认可。我相信你实际完成的事情清单，远比你允许自己去思考的要长得多。你太谦虚了。你实在太谦虚了。即使你仍然觉得自己落后，看着那份清单，心想：“天哪，也许吧，实际上那还是不够好。”落后于谁？
Behind what? Every person that you are like comparing yourself to, they have their own insecurities. They have things that they would look at you and they would look at your life and say, wow, yeah, I have this great career and I like have all these things. But like I never actually got to really just like, explore what I wanted. And actually, I never got to really, like, travel and I never got to do those crazy nights with my friends and, like, all I ever did was work. Like, it's, the grass is always greener. That is like one of the best ways to summarize this entire episode. So much of our sense
落后于什么？每一个你拿来与自己比较的人，他们都有自己的不安全感。他们也有一些事情，当他们看着你、看着你的生活时会说：“哇，是的，我有这份很棒的事业，我拥有所有这些东西。但我从来没有真正去探索过我想要的东西。而且，我从来没有真正去旅行过，也从来没有和朋友们度过那些疯狂的夜晚，我所做的一切就是工作。”这就像是“邻家草坪总是更绿”。这几乎是总结这一整集节目最好的方式之一。我们很大一部分的
of inadequacy is perception based. And it's based on who you're comparing yourself to. The fact that you are not acknowledging what you have survived and endured, it's based on on the fact that you're comparing yourself to a life or an other standard or an idea of where you should be that was determined by people like 50, 60 years ago and that world just doesn't exist yet. And it's a perception issue because you are believing that the most valuable experiences that you could have or the most valuable thing you could be is somebody who is successful, who has accolades and who has achievements. And you are not counting your failures and your experiences and the fun that you've had, the same way. You are not valuing that as in
不满足感是基于感知的。它取决于你拿自己和谁比较。你没有承认你所幸存和忍受的一切，这是基于你将自己与一种生活、一种标准，或者一种关于你应该处于什么位置的观念进行比较，而这些标准是由50、60年前的人们所决定的，那个世界现在根本不存在了。这是一个感知问题，因为你相信你能拥有的最有价值的经历，或者你能成为的最有价值的人，就是一个成功的人，一个拥有荣誉和成就的人。而你并没有以同样的方式去计算你的失败、你的经历和你所享受的乐趣。你没有把这些视为
equal measure as the stuff that other people value. And I think if you were to really take those things as important and really saw them as like the currency of a good life, like you would have a lot more kindness to yourself. And I would hope that you would really realize like how much you really have going for you and how much you've achieved. So that, my friends, is the five reasons. I think it's more than five, but let's say six, six. reasons. I don't think you're as behind as you think you are. I hope this episode has been a bit of a solve for your worries and your anxieties that I often share. I feel this very, very deeply as well. It is just a quintessential experience of this time in your life. Take it with a grain of salt.
与他人所珍视的东西同等重要。我认为，如果你真的把这些事情视为重要的，并真正把它们看作是美好生活的货币，你就会对自己多一份善意。我希望你真的能意识到你拥有多少优势，以及你取得了多少成就。所以，朋友们，这就是那五个理由。我想不止五个，但我们就说是六个，六个理由。我不认为你像你想象的那样落后。我希望这一集节目能为你经常分享的担忧和焦虑提供一点解决办法。我也对此感同身受。这只是你人生这个阶段的一种典型体验。别太当真。
Please know that. It's a feeling we just kind of have to endure. So I hope that this has helped you endure it a little bit better. If you have made it this far and you are listening on Spotify, leave a little white heart emoji below. Let me know that you made it to the end. I hope you enjoyed the episode. And if you haven't yet check out an episode on Netflix, please. It's like one of the easiest ways to help us out. And just to show Netflix, show people that the podcast and video form matters.
请记住这一点。这是一种我们不得不忍受的感觉。所以我希望这能帮助你更好地忍受它。如果你已经看到了这里，并且正在Spotify上收听，请在下方留下一个白色爱心表情符号。让我知道你坚持到了最后。希望你喜欢这一集。如果你还没有在Netflix上观看过节目，请务必去看一下。这是帮助我们最简单的方法之一，也是向Netflix和大众证明播客和视频形式的重要性。
Obviously, you don't have to. But it would be, I would very much appreciate it. Thank you as always to our researcher, Lucy Davidson. If you want more content like this, you can follow us on Instagram. You can follow us on Substack. want episode transcripts or shorter version of these episodes delivered directly to your inbox. But until next time, be safe, be kind. Remember that you are not as behind as your little silly brain thinks that you are. We will talk very, very soon.
当然，你不必这样做。但我会非常感激。一如既往地感谢我们的研究员露西·戴维森。如果你想要更多这样的内容，可以在Instagram上关注我们。你也可以关注我们的Substack。如果你想直接在收件箱中收到这些剧集的文字稿或精简版，请关注我们。但下次见之前，请注意安全，保持善良。记住，你并没有你那愚蠢的小脑袋瓜想的那么落后。我们很快就会再聊。
Lisa, tell them about our new show. We have a new podcast. It's called Don't Lie to Me. I'm Lexi Youanu. We're two best friends, 22 years apart, but so close at heart. And I'm Lisa Di Giulio, the old one, which means we have wildly different references, occasionally different opinions, and at this point in my 50s, I've lived it all. Now in my 30s, being the founder of new shoes, good taste is my business. Listen on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Lacey Mosley, author, actor, stand-up comedian, creator, and host of Scam Goddess Podcast. The True Crime Comedy Podcasts, all about robbery, fraud, and those who practice it.
丽莎，告诉大家我们的新节目。我们有一个新的播客，叫《别对我撒谎》。我是莱克西·尤阿努。我们是两个最好的朋友，相差22岁，但心意相通。我是丽莎·迪·朱利奥，年长的那位，这意味着我们有截然不同的参考系，偶尔有不同的观点，而且在我50多岁的时候，我已经历了一切。现在我30多岁，作为新鞋品牌的创始人，好品味就是我的事业。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。我是莱西·莫斯利，作家、演员、单口喜剧演员，也是《骗子女神》播客的创作者和主持人。这是一档关于抢劫、欺诈以及那些行骗之人的真实犯罪喜剧播客。
Each week I bring on an amazing guest. Ooh, I scammed them. What? I can talk to you for an hour. You're a generational yapper like me. That's why I had to make yapping a job. And now you can catch full episodes of my show on YouTube. Start listening to Scam Goddess on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
每周我都会邀请一位很棒的嘉宾。噢，我骗了他们。什么？我可以和你聊一个小时。你和我一样是个滔滔不绝的人。这就是为什么我必须把“滔滔不绝”变成一份工作。现在你可以在YouTube上观看我节目的完整剧集。开始在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《骗子女神》吧。
Scam Goddess! Hi, this is Kylie Breakman. Angel Geratana. Jeremy Colhane. Patrick McDonald. And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists Podcast. The Improvised Character Comedy Podcast. where each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft. Join us for a panel of Eurovision participants.
《骗子女神》！大家好，我是凯莉·布雷克曼。安吉尔·杰拉塔纳。杰里米·科尔汉。帕特里克·麦克唐纳。我们是《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》播客的主持人。这是一档即兴角色喜剧播客，每周都会有一组新的艺术家讨论他们的技艺。欢迎加入我们，参加欧洲歌唱大赛参赛者的专题讨论。
And we do a little Halloween sometimes. Does the Pope dress up? He winks on Halloween. He gets right up next to the microphone. I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween. Listen to Artists on Artists on Artists every Thursday on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
我们有时也会过万圣节。教皇会打扮吗？他在万圣节会眨眼。他会凑到麦克风前。我听说你几乎能听到睫毛撞击的声音。你从未见过意大利像教皇在万圣节眨眼时那样安静。请在每周四通过IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》。
Welcome to Decoding Women's Health. I'm Dr. Elizabeth Pointer, chair of women's health and gynecology at the Atria Health Institute in New York City. I'll be talking to top researchers and clinicians and bringing vital information about midlife women's health directly to you. A hundred percent of women go through menopause. Even if it's natural, why should we suffer through it? Listen to Decoding Women's Health with Dr. Elizabeth Pointer on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You broke me. You do not deserve happiness. I'm Andrea Gunning. On this season of betrayal, Carl thought he was living a normal drama-free life until the messages started. Someone's not going to make it out of this alive. Every piece of evidence pointed to the wrong guy.
欢迎收听《解码女性健康》。我是伊丽莎白·波因特医生，纽约Atria健康研究所女性健康与妇科主任。我将与顶尖的研究人员和临床医生交谈，为您带来关于中年女性健康的至关重要的信息。百分之百的女性都会经历更年期。即使它是自然的，我们为什么要忍受它呢？请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听伊丽莎白·波因特医生主持的《解码女性健康》。你毁了我。你不配得到幸福。我是安德里亚·甘宁。在这一季的《背叛》中，卡尔以为自己过着正常、无忧无虑的生活，直到那些信息开始出现。有人无法活着离开这里。每一条证据都指向了错误的人。
He was not going to stop unless we stopped him. Listen to Betrayal Season 6 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
除非我们阻止他，否则他不会停手。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《背叛》第六季。这是一个IHeart播客。保证由人类制作。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。